arrivé dans le quartier de la chapelle
dans le xviiie arrondissement de paris
c'est d'abord passer une frontière
invisible marquant une séparation nette
entre ici et le reste de la capitale
entre ici et la normalité
je vous ai cité cette première phrase de
l'article de charles magistris un
article édifiant qui est publié dans le
figaro magazine de ce week-end il est
allé à la rencontre des habitants de ce
quartier qui n'en peuvent plus
augmentation de l'insécurité
environnement qui se dégradent leur vie
est devenue un enfer
écoutez ce qu'en disait anne hidalgo la
maire de paris c'était il ya quelques
mois la démarche que nous accomplissons
est une démarche visant d'une part à
dire à l'état c'est de sa responsabilité
d'accueillir les personnes à la rue et
les personnes réfugiées et immigrantes
il est arrivé un moment où pour nous pas
rimé avec nos voisins on a estimé qu' on
était au bout du rouleau
au bout du rouleau de ce qu'on pouvait
supporter en tant que ville en tant
qu'élu mais bien sûr je pense aussi aux
riverains et je pense évidemment aux
personnes qui sont dans des conditions
d'indignité total dans la rue richard
brigue donc ça c'était il ya un mois
c'est pas un peu facile pour la maire de
paris de rejeter la responsabilité sur
l'état dans cette situation l'extrême
vous avez passé justement un moment où
ce n'est pas que la maire de paris elle
est entourée de 18 maires de communes
qui à un moment donné ont décidé de
pousser ensemble créé en disant stop
nous n'avons plus les moyens ne savons
plus faire nous avons besoin de lait que
l'état prenne ses responsabilités pour
faire ensemble
c'était ça le propos de cette journée
est de ce moment on voit quelle qu'elle
n'est pas seule à s'exprimer en tant que
maire de paris bien évidemment enfin on
va pas se cacher que la situation est
difficile voire même dramatique pour les
personnes qui habitent dans ce quartier
enfin faut être très clair la situation
néanmoins je ne sais pas si l'idée de
dire c'est de la faute de l'un ou c'est
la faute de l'autre va un moment donné
permettent d'avancer ce que je vois
simplement c'est qu'il ya une situation
qui n'est plus tolérable et qu'il faut
trouver les moyens d'en sortir
le préfet a demandé à la maire de paris
des terrains sur lesquels ils pourraient
installer 2
nouveau camp de migrants dans paris deux
sites ont été récemment proposée par la
maire de paris dans le xviième et dans
le 12e arrondissement et en l'occurrence
je peux en parler puisque c'est là en
disant dans lequel suravenir adjoint et
que ce n'est pas la première fois que le
12e arrondissement prend sa part dans la
mise en place d'un centre avec accueil
de migrants pour à la fois des mises à
l'abri mais aussi un travail sur
l'orientation et un travail sur ce que
l'on peut faire avec les personnes qui
arrivent parce que la situation telle
qu'elle est décrite aujourd'hui à la
chapelle enfin il n'a pas besoin d'un
article supplémentaire cet article dit
des choses bon avec des mots parfois
qu'ils sont un petit peu je pense que
sans les voix des habitants
non la partie des ongs lisse et pas un
mot des habitants et c'est un mot qu'on
aurait pu éviter semences dans l'article
mais peu importe ça reste quand même
d'aller sur place qui a vu le nom mais
qu'avant son travail de zombies au lieu
de parler de personne je trouve qu'à un
moment donné faut faire attention aux
mauves pas en rajouter la situation est
assez difficile comme ça mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi prendre le recul de
cela voilà moi je pense que quand l'état
prend ses responsabilités quand l'âge il
prend ses responsabilités que faire de
plus on est en pleines élections
européennes vous avez vu que ce sujet là
du tout été mis en avant peut-être c'est
bien peut-être aussi ça aurait pu être
un sujet qu'ils fassent qui fasse
campagne parce que je pense qu'il ya
au-delà de ce qui se passe à la chapelle
est un phénomène plus général et que
l'europe a aussi peut-être des choses à
dire sur ce sujet vous parliez du 12e
arrondissement
vous avez déjà un
un endroit
précis ou parce que l'état est en train
de faire le tour des différents sites
qui pourraient accueillir ce centre
s'assurer que c'est possible s'assurer
que on peut le faire de manière à la
fois en sécurité et que la logistique
puisse être aussi organisé il ya déjà un
centre unc a été installé il ya quelques
mois qu'elle est gérée par une
association qui s'appelle l'aurore ça
s'est bien passé ça se passe bien parce
que les conditions et avec l'état et la
ville ont été étudiées pour que ça se
passe le mieux possible
adriana tout ce qui est décrit quand
même dans l'arctique c'est assez
effrayant décrivent des vols des
agressions des assassinats des meurtres
devant devant les gens c'est et il
évoque même une situation d'une zone de
non droit ouais bah c'est à l'ordre en
fait c'est très compliqué de dire à qui
la faute parce que je pense qu'il ya
tout un tas de deux responsables de
responsabilité qui s'entremêlent je
pense que quand même il ya le premier
responsable service les pouvoirs publics
au sens large puisque ce qui est décrit
dans l'article c'est quand même des gens
qui commettent des délits et des crimes
qui restent impunis j'ai été marqué par
le témoignage d'un coq de boxe qui a dit
ici c'est la loi du talion
donc je fais des descentes parce que
voilà pour faire régner l'ordre
il ya des bandes rivales voilà il ya
quand même les batailles de territoire
c'est quand même le rôle de l'état alors
ensuite on peut parler de la question
des associations leur travail de terrain
est vraiment je pense utile après il est
peut-être même une pragmatique du
discours parce que par exemple il ya un
autre témoignage dans cet article qui
suit de mourad qui tient un commerce et
qui se fait traiter de raciste parce
qu'il met en question voilà alors que ce
monsieur a quand même fui l'algérie pour
offir reste limité dans les années 90 je
pense qu'il ya peut-être un problème
dans certaines associations
de gauche qui commandent hier qui
valorise les migrations en soi alors que
je ne suis pas sûr que ces personnes
rêvent d'aller de devenir accro au crack
porte de la chapelle et peut-être un
discours weck est un enfer c'est savoir
atteindre alors pays se retrouve c'est
pas vraiment le paradis je pense qu'il
ya un discours parfois un peu sans
frontiérisme qui peut être négatif
et enfin je veux quand même signaler qu'
il ya quand même un problème de
répartition de l'effort parce que moi je
me rappelle quand même que dès qu'il ya
un projet de mettre un centre de
réfugiés ou du sdf dans le 16e
arrondissement
les habitants se mobilisent tous pour
qu'il y ai absolument aucune personne en
difficulté qu'ils soient accueillis dans
l'arrondissement dont il ya quand même
ce problème là on ne peut pas à la fois
dire c'est une zone de non droit c'est
un scandale porte de la chapelle et
refuser de répartir un minimum les
personnes donc je pense que voilà il ya
beaucoup de responsabilités qui
s'additionnent gîte waintraub les
municipales sont dans moins d'un an
on voit bien que si c'est pas là un des
sujets de la campagne européenne ça peut
l'être pour les la bataille des
municipales d'ailleurs il ya un certain
nombre de tweets qui qui réagissent
parce que cet article fait énormément
réagir
rachida dati qui vaut le lisais en même
temps que moi il est urgent d'agir il
est rodé facile de se défausser sur
l'état gaspard ganzer lui-même candidat
qui a fait un tweet ça va être un enjeu
de la campagne
mais c'est un enjeu de la campagne
d'ailleurs dire que ça n'est pas un
sujet de la campagne c'est trop rapide
parce que certains candidats ne veulent
pas ce soit un sujet de la campagne vous
souvienne des européennes
je me suis dit on parle par an je me
souviens d'une étude you gouv assez
récente qui plaçait l'immigration en
tête
absolument des préoccupations d'aidé
des gens interrogés dans toute l'europe
ce cd des études massive on n'est pas
sur le petit sondage et même sur les
sondages par préoccupation vous avez le
pouvoir d'achat et l'immigration qui se
remplacent la l'autre au premier rang
avec l'environnement mais en tout cas
c'est une c'est une c'est une
préoccupation majeure mais qui est
délibérément occultés par certains
candidats plutôt de gauche est plutôt en
marche et plutôt écolo est d'ailleurs de
ce point de vue là je trouve qu'il ya
comme un gros progrès qu on doit saluer
dans l'intervention d'anne hidalgo c'est
qu'elle n'est plus dans le déni
rappelez vous il ya pas si longtemps ça
ne pose de aucun problème les gens
prennent plutôt venu on va vous aurez
absolument donc elle devrait aussi
regarder le bilan de la politique
qu'elle a mené maintenant que à bout de
souffle dit elle ou au bout du rouleau
pardon ou du rouleau donc changement de
discours bienvenus cela dit deux types
de problèmes
un type 2
comment gérer les gens qui sont sur
place évidemment la réponse est dans les
conditions les plus humaine possible et
les plus sûres possibles pour eux pour
elle est pour et pour les habitants et
puis à l'éternel problème du non renvoi
des étrangers ou déboutés du droit
d'asile et qui pendant que vous n'aurez
pas vous ne serez pas attaquer
sérieusement à ce problème là vous
n'arriverez pas à résoudre le poivre le
problème de gestion des personnes en
déshérence dans ces quartiers et
d'ailleurs je finis par là je remarque
la question est évoquée par exemple dans
le programme de la république en marche
mais deux phases de façon incantatoire
il faut il faut améliorer le retour des
déboutés du droit d'asile dans le
programme de la république en marche
dans le programme des républicains phare
dans la proposition est de conditionner
l'aide au développement des pays dont
les migrants sont ressortissants par
leur acceptation des retours c'était une
proposition que emmanuel macron avait
envisagé rappelez-vous à propos quand
ils étaient en afrique à propos des
femmes excisées ou des pays qui
maltraitent qui tolérait les
maltraitances aux familles avait dit je
conditionnerait l'aide aux le l'aide au
développement au traitement que ces pays
font d'eux des fables il n'avait pas mis
cette menace à exécution c'est dommage
alors on a interrogé
on vous a interrogé sur twitter selon
vous la mairie de paris en fait elle
assez pour lutter contre l'insécurité et
l'environnement dégradé de la porte de
la chapelle et c'est je crois que c'est
assez clair 90%
vous répondez non mais dans vos messages
sur lefigaro.fr c'est plus mitigé nicole
qui dit ça fait combien d'années que la
chapelle est un vrai coupe gorge et un
lieu sans d'roches pas si c'est
rassurant de de se dire que ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
babineau qui disent c'est trop facile de
pointer du doigt la mairie de paris
l'état doit agir c'est lui le
responsable
les maires ont tiré la sonnette et
ronito qui nous dit on est dans
l'hypocrisie générale personne ne
cherche réellement à résoudre la
situation
arnaud bénédicte et en matière de comme
vous diriez quoi l'état bien joué parce
que finalement ça bon ça le mistigri est
tombé sur la mairie de paris anne
hidalgo assure que l'état ait bien joué
parce que de toute façon vous avez trois
sujets vous avez un premier sujet qui
est un sujet j'ai dit à presque
macropolitique est celui du contrôle et
de la gestion des flux migratoires et sa
relève d'abord de l'espace européen on
voit bien que sur cette question
l'europe est en train de se fracturer
parce que c'est clairement la question
migratoire aujourd'hui qui est à
l'origine des principales facture que
connaît l'union européenne et qui relève
aussi quand même une compétence de
l'état après vous avez un deuxième sujet
qui est un sujet qui est celui de
l'ordre public le maintien de l'ordre
public quand même dans une république
comme la france ça reste malgré tout
d'une responsabilité qui est celle de
l'état et vous avez un troisième sujet
qui est le sujet j'allais dire du vivre
ensemble de la cohabitation des
communautés ou là en effet les
politiques municipales peuvent
éventuellement disons mettre un peu de
j'allais dire un peu d'huile dans l'est
dans l'est dans l'est dans les rouages
mais en fait vous avez aujourd'hui des
groupements politiques qu'il s'agisse de
l'europe de l'état et des municipalités
qui sont quand même profondément
déstabilisé par la question migratoire
et qui n'ont pas les moyens
véritablement ou peut-être pas la
volonté aussi au niveau européen de
gérer ces flux
ces flux migratoires on change
complètement de sujets comment assurer
une défense efficace quand son client
n'y met pas un peu du sien
c'est l'équation visiblement impossible
que doit résoudre